قائد قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه اهلا بك
هذه المره نلتقي في شمال شرق سوريا في ظرف
غير اعتيادي مع تحديدات تركيه تتزايد بشني
عمليات ضدكم
مؤخرا كنت حدد مكانا وزمانا واضحا جدا
لهذه العمليه قلت انها ستكون في كوباني
ما المعلومات التي ستنتهم عليها
الاطراف
استنتجنا بعد تقييم الاوضاع ان تركيا تريد
سنه هجوم بريه على مناطقنا قبل الانتخابات
الرئاسيه والهجوم الذي سيركزون عليه سيكون
في كوباني
ونتوقع ان تفضي المحادثات الجاريه حاليا
بين الروس والاتراك والنظام السوري الى
مساومه اوصفقه بشان شني عمليه في كوباني
التي ستكون بين تركيا روسيا والنظام
السوري
النظام السوري والقوات الاخرى لن تسمح
بوقو هجوم او احتلال تركي في تلك المناطق
لكنها لن تبده اهتماما بمصير كوباني وفيه
حواراتنا مع كافه الاطراف ادركنا ذلك
هل تحدثهم حول هذه العمليه التركيه
المرتقبه
على طلب منكم شيء
في الملفات الامنيه والعسكريه لان
الاقاليم التي تنوي تركي استهدافها يتواجد
بها نحو 12000 عنصر من قوات النظام السوري
ويوجد تنسيق بيننا طلبنا منهم التصدي لاي
هجوم تركي لكن النظام السوري لم يرد علينا
حتى الان بشان مواجهه الاحتلال التركي
وهذا واجبهم تحدث
سيد مظلوم عن ااا مقايضه او تسويه تركيه
روسيه مع النظام السوري تتعلق بكم
على تخشون كذلك من مقايضه بين الامريكيين
والاتراك
وبن تكون هذه المقايضه على حساب
الاداره الذاتيه او قصد
جميل
موقفا بشان الاحتلال التركي
نطالبهم باتخاد مواقف اكثر جديه ولا اعتقد
ان هناك تفاهمات او صفقه بين الاتراك
الامريكيين
ما شكل التعاون او المساعده الامريكيه
الماموله
كما تعلمون نحن مع القوات الامريكيه
والتحالف نتعاون في قتال داعش والشيء الذي
نطلبه الان من الاداره الامريكيه ان
يتعاونوا مع الاداره الذاتيه وقصد سياسيا
وليس امنيا فقط في شمال سوريا
كما حصل سابقا
فلن نستطيع مواصلات قتالنا ضد داعش لهذا
نرى ذلك امرا خطرا منذ ثمانيه سنوات نحن
والقوات الامريكيه نقاتل دا وكان القتال
عنيفا ووصلنا الى قناعه بان التعاون
العسكري وحده غير كافن لقتال داعش يجب ان
يكون هناك دعما سياسيا واقتصاديا للاداره
الذاتيه للقضاء على تنظيم نهائيا وان لم
يكن المستقبل السياسي واضح فان المعركه ضد
داعش ستكون في خطر
ما الذي ستطلبونه تحديدا من الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه في حال تركيا عمليه
شكل المساعده
عدم فتح المجال الجوي لتركيا والامر كذلك
بالنسبه لروسيا وفي حال فتح المجال الجوي
فذلك يعني موافقتهما على الهجوم التركي
وفي الامر الثاني كان هناك قرار صديق من
الكونجرس الامريكي بفرض عقوبات على تركيا
نطالب بتجديد تلك العقوبات وتوسيعها
واعتقدوا ان فدت امريكا ذلك فلن تستطيع
تركيا الهجوم
في سؤالها هل تبتزون الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه والتحالف
بحديثكم عن تعليق التعاون في محاربه داعش
صحيح ومن يتحدث بذلك فان نيته سيئه
الامريكيون يعرفون اكثر من هذه المساله
نحن نقاتل معهم ويعرفون الحقيقه وفي حاله
وقوعه هجوم تركي فلن نتمكن من القتال على
جبهتين ضد داعش وضد ثاني اقوى دوله عسكريه
في نيته
امكانياتنا ليست بهذا الحجم مقاتلون الذين
يحرسون السجونهم مقاتلون اكراد
ومنازلهم على الحدود واي هجوم تركي
سيدفعهم الى ترك السجون والذهاب للحفاظ
على عائلاتهم
حتى الامريكيين هو علاقه محتمله بينكم
وبين حزب العمال الكردستاني
ما طبيعه العلاقه اليوم بين اسد
العمال الكردستاني
الهجوم على مناطقنا نعمل مع الامريكيين
على الارض ويعلمون ان قيادات قصد سوريون
ولدين واجب نحو سوريا واوضح ذلك بشكل رسمي
على قناتكم بانه لا علاقه تنظيميه رسميه
او صله لنا مع حزب العمال الكردستاني
كم منظمه سياسيه سوريه ودعيني اضيف شيان
اخر هناك عدد كبير من مقاتلي حزب العمال
الكردستاني شاركوا معنا في القتال ضد داعش
ونحو اربعه الاف عنصر منهم قتلوا هنا وادو
واجبهم القومي الكردي قسم كبير
كيف تتحدثون عن هذا الانفصال بينكم وبين
العمال الكردستاني ان كنتم توصفون دائما
بالفرع السوري اللي هي العمري
الكردستانيرجي الحديث دائما كذلك عن ولاء
وارتباط بعض عناصر قصد وقيادات قصد
بالعمال الكردستاني
داخل قصد
يدعم العمال الكردستاني ويتشدد مع الجانب
التركي فيما انتم همم اتمنى تصحيح هذه
المعلومه انتم التيار الاخر الاقل تشددا
والداعي اكثر لتهدئه مع تركيا
ابي يعني
يقال دائما ويعود الى ان رئيس حزب العمال
الكردستاني عبد الله اوجلان عاش هنا 20
سنه وكثير من اهالي المنطقه متعلقون به
فكريا ولهذا السبب يقال اننا مرتبطون بحزب
العمال واستطيع ان اقول بثقه حاليا انا
جندتنا سوريا اولا لكن بعض الاشخاص
السوريين عملوا مع حزب العمال سابقا
ويمارسون واجباتهم تجاه سوريا دعيني اقول
لك بصدق اننا في قصد نقاتل داعش منذ عشر
سنوات
فريقنا واحد ولا يوجد بيننا تباينات او
تيارات او اتجاهات مختلفه او انقسامات
على الكثير من صور عبد الله اوجلان هنا في
شمال سوريا
لماذا تستمر تركيا وحتى الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه في عدم تصديق الحديث عن فك
الارتباط بينكما
ان الولايات المتحده
ترغب بخفض التصعيد بين سوريا وتركيا لذا
هم يريدون معالجه الذرائع التركيه كونهم
اصطنعوا ازمه من ملف حزب العمال
الكردستاني مخاوف وتركيا واقعيه ليست من
حزب الع لكنها من القضيه الكرديه كونهم
اكدوا سابقا انهم لن يسمحوا بتكرار تجربه
شمال العراق في شمال شرق سوريا
محل اللاعب الاخر المهم
سياحه سوريه روسيا
كنت طلبتهم وساطه من الجانب الروسي هل
هناك اي مستجدات حول هذه الوساطه هل طرح
عليكم اي مقترح جديد
فلسطين
وبساطه الروسيه عقدنا اتفاق سوتشي لخفض
التصعيد بين الرئيسين بوتين واردوغان وهي
اتفاقيه مستمره حتى الان الشيء الذي يطلبه
من الروس حاليا هو الالتزام بهذه
الاتفاقيه لان الاتراك يتهموننا بعدم
الالتزام بها نحن ملتزمون لكن تركيا هي
الطرف غير الملتزم بالاتفاق مطالب الروس
بالزامهم بذلك للحفاظ على خفض التصعيد
بيننا
في هذه المساله
بجنن
يريدون ابعاد جميع قواتنا عن الحدود
قواتنا غير موجوده على الحدود لكنه هناك
قوات الامن الداخلي فقط
ولنقبل بعدهم كما يريد الاتراك توسيع
اتفاقيه اضنه لتصل الى 30 كلم
خمس فقط من جانبنا لن نقبل بذلك ولا نعلم
بعد موقف الروس من ذلك
من تعتقدون بانه سيكون الداعم الاكبر او
ربما حتى الوحيد لكم
انا زلمه
مستعد للقتال ام لا نطلب منهم المساعده
الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد صرح سابقا بان
جنود الجيش سيحاربون في المناطق
المتواجدين بها لكن من جانبنا التحضيرات
جيده لمجاهد اي هجوم سنحارب في كوباني
ستكون حربا كبيرا تسبب دمارا لكن الاتراك
لن يحققوا هدفهم والجميع سيتضرر من هذه
المواجهه
انتم تسيطرون على نحو ربع
مساحه سوريا هل لديكم تصور او توقع
للمستقبل الاداره الذاتيه في شمال شرق
سوريا
القائمه منذ عشر سنوات
والاعتراف بها دستوريا والهدف الثاني ان
تستلم قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه والامن
الداخلي الملفين الامني والعسكري تحت مظله
الجيش السوري في المستقبل لدينا ايمان
بهذا المشروع تحت العلم والحدود السوريه
مع كل ما يجيك من تطورات على الحدود مع
تهديدات تركيا هل تعتقد فعلا انكم قادرون
على الاستمرار بهذا الوضع الاداره الذاتيه
في شمال شرق سوريا النظام السوري هل سيقبل
هذا الوضع
لكن اذا اخرجت تركيا من المعادله كونهم
العائق الاكبر
سنصلوا لحل مع النظام السوري
في كوباني تحديدا في حاله ان تركيا فعلا
هذه العمليه ما الذي سيحدث
لماذا كوباني هدف في تركيا القديم هو وصل
المناطق التي تسيطر عليها والمعروفه بدرع
الفرات ونبع السلام لذلك تسعى الاحتلال
كوباني كهدف لها منذ امد طويل لاطاله
الاحتلال التركي في الداخل السوري من
ناحيه اخرى شعبنا في كوباني ومقاتلونا
مستعدون للقتال هناك قبل تسع سنوات
هذه المره ليس فقد القرد بل العرب واكراد
المنطقه سياتون للقتال هناك ولدينا
تجهيزات نعم سيحدث دمار وحرب كبيره تستمر
لعمد طويل وسنكون لائقين باسم كوباني
ومقاومتنا ستستمر
[موسيقى]
حدث عنها السيد مطلوب تحفرون انفاق
ليس لدينا طائرات
ولحمايه قواتنا وشعبنا من الهجمات التركيه
حفرنا الانفاق لتشكيل نظام دفاعيا ذاتي
متكامل
هل زاد الدعم الامريكي في فتره الاخيره
التي تدخل تحمل المحروقات
واردوغان يقول انها اسلحه وبالالاف هذا
الدعاء الكبير ما يزودنا به الامريكيون
اسلحه فرديه خفيفه لقتال داعش فقط ولا
نمتلك اي اسلحه اخرى
ولاضيف شيئا اخر نمتلك تجهيزات كبيره
وسنكون قادرين على حمايت انفسنا وفقا
لقدراتنا الذاتيه
السيد قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه شكرا على
قبول الحديث معنا هنا في شمال الشرق سوريا